so what do we want to watch zombie baby
I think the real question is what do we
want to eat I'm not hungry
the answer is pizza you guys this order
maybe I'll have a bite we definitely
need to get the cheesy bites crust but
I'm open to any toppings I'm thinking
salami and green peppers what it has to
be pepperoni yeah
what you know this isn't my first pizza
rodeo I feel like Gabi just needs to
respect my topping choices Dave thinks
he knows what's best for everyone but he
doesn't know what's good for me and my
body and my body wants pepperoni I love
pizza I love all pizza toppings but
today I'm gonna go with pepperoni
because Gabi loves pepperoni and I love
Gabi can't believe I just said that
salami in Greece always Jews I'm just
saying it's a great flavor combo Oh
guys can we just get two pizzas
Oh hunger Gabi if we don't make it I
want you to know it's here not that I
care
hi how you doing hey yay who's got the
money
I'll get I'll get it Oh guys don't worry
about it
gonna stain
this is great
alright last slice
anybody want it I shouldn't Dave ah I
give it to Brad I mean my mom says it's
ready to take the last slice and she
took it
what I'm hungry now you're hungry
so what do you guys want to watch zombie
baby